[Música]
eu queria agradecer o conflito foi o
convite de agradecer a todos que estão
presentes e todos aqueles que mesmo não
estando presentes vão assistir esta
conversa quando comunicaram pela
primeira vez
qual seria o tema desta intervenção a
nossa voz à voz não conseguiu evitar de
compreender com uma afirmação política
não necessariamente ideológica com
certeza não sectária mas definitivamente
política a nossa voz é o que é nosso
enquanto coletivo e sobretudo que usa
para todos os outros não somos nós não
somos nós
desde a pré história até a contemporânea
foram vários os meios e os dias técnicas
que a humanidade encontrou ainda
acrescentando a necessidade de comunicar
a ansiedade partilhar com os seus
clientes
a forma como compreender a si próprio ea
forma como compreendo o mundo envolvente
entre elas naturalmente a música som
mono convicto e confesso
a música foi é uma parte importante da
minha vida
o que eu proponho seguida com vocês é
partilhar meia dúzia considerações que
ilustram a minha relação com música mas
também necessariamente com o mundo e com
o estado atual das coisas é algo
primordial nessa necessidade humana de
partilhar com os seus semelhantes
a forma como se concebe a si próprio e
ao mundo junto não será muito usado
neste momento afirmar que desde a pré
história a música foi assumido como um
veículo primordial
está sempre aqui um veículo privilegiado
de comunicação e também em maio com
potencial gregário indiscutível
agregarem de vídeo
eu não consigo escolher a lista além da
imagem
tá tá nada quer do outro lado da minha
cabeça é grave
vamos tentar continuar assim será um
reconhecimento tácito e universal da
eficácia comunicacional da música e seu
potencial de agregar indivíduos que vai
determinar ao longo de toda a história
com música com o poder e com os povos
durante toda a história nacional em
curso não poder falar a uma só voz em
regra são duas ações por um lado o poder
político
todas as vozes são vários
[Música]
quando pensamos que a nova situação e
fazer da música um papel fundamental
e essa música vai ser a principal
responsável de comunicação significa em
linguagem há um outro momento histórico
determinante na música a cultura a
música é uma época tecnológicos de
aparelhos eletrodomésticos permitem a
fruição de música em casa a produção ea
música em casa de todos destaca
naturalmente
e essa rádio essas inovações
tecnológicas vão ser utilizadas pelos
estados totalitários para a dupla campeã
o do estado
os liberais e para disseminar por entre
os 20 e os setores
uma imagem idealizada da sociedade
todas as vozes de fazer com o recurso a
esta altura tanto em poucos minutos
em poucos minutos e contemporânea e
contemporânea em tron um pouco afastado
há muito tempo e chegamos à época o pós
guerra é guerra é novo uma época de
grandes avanços
um dos momentos fundamentais e e e
determinantes na música neste momento um
crescimento exponencial no número em
poder comprar uma classe média e na
goleada pelo consumo e dj novas
sensações
é óbvio que essa classe média história
de imdiato alvo de uma comunicação
social cada vez mais agressiva e cada
vez mais ficava num mercado e no consumo
apesar de ser a classe média é eleita o
alvo privilegiado da comunicação social
da comunicação nos vagas dos mass media
avaí a sociedade continuam extremamente
identificada segregados e uma franja
populacional que não é considerada
na programação oficial convencional
neste momento oscilava entre o
entretenimento conservador e propaganda
subliminar é óbvio que essas classes
segregava não lhes era permitido o
acesso ou maio os meios convencionais
difusão de cultura e música
no entanto porque realmente havia essa
possibilidade existia essas classes
essas franjas populacionais subalternas
tem pela primeira vez na história a
possibilidade de fazer ouvir a sua voz e
difundirem forma massiva destes dessas
franjas populacionais essas margens da
sociedade consumista vencerá da mudança
do século 20 as manifestações musicais
rock que vão determinar a forma como nós
vamos perceber a música e vamos produzir
música
fundamentalmente até hoje as estruturas
que é música das margens difundiam era
uma estrutura simbólica e
simultaneamente protesto e sua vitória
obviamente era uma visão que era
concebida nas margens e protestava
contra a exclusão contra contra a
marginalização que essas populações
afetadas mas simultaneamente
são palavras o facto de uma forma
perversa era exatamente essa condição de
exclusão que lhe permitiria viver
afastados dos convênios de produção de
cultura e das tradições rurais e dos
pré-requisitos de virtuosismo produzir
para produzir música era também um
exercício de liberdade tanto que vai
acrescentar a introdução dessa música
das margens é isso caráter emancipatório
libertário que se mantém até hoje para
baixo no momento em que música com sons
ou fundir universalmente massivamente
essa estrutura simbólica o produziu foi
agressão de uma série de indivíduos do
mundo que se identificavam com essas
estruturas com mais ou menos razão se
sentiram excluídos o que pretendiam
viverá excluídos desse discurso
dominante até hoje foram produzidas
várias originaram várias linhagens que
se reclamam de seus propósitos originais
da música da música produzida na sua
volta o punk rock com certeza um deus
web meta é com certeza um deus e reação
à ameaça foi tal relação foi
proporcional do poder político usou
todos os meios e todas as técnicas
pinhão dispor da marginalização violenta
a exclusão dos meios de difusão
convencionais
a perseguição e prisão dos artistas mas
usou mais um que foi proporcionado pela
conjuntural da indústria da cultura e do
poder do mercado consumo ou seja pela
primeira vez os poderes dominantes
tenham o seu acesso a capacidade de
identificar qualquer tipo de evidência
inclusivamente os mais ameaçadores
modificação modificação é quando o poder
central se apropria de um fenômeno
cultural envolve volta à população sob a
forma de um banco consumível desprovido
de todo o conteúdo ético e representava
uma forma sedutora estética é este mundo
que nós vivemos hoje
transformar técnica científica
particularmente no âmbito das ciências
da comunicação das ciências da
informação em 2000 ver praticamente
imediata a primeira é rápida do produto
hoje vivemos numa altura em que não
conseguimos acompanhar o consumidor não
consegue acompanhar os lançamentos
fonográficos que acontecem no mundo tal
como acontece com fotografia tal como
acontece com algum tipo de jornalismo a
música sofre exatamente o mesmo problema
é um é um
há um novo flow de informação que nos
permite acompanhar a música
entretanto foi localizada nas redes
tradicionais de fusão e hoje é maior
parte das pessoas consomem música via
itub via redes sociais vêm eventualmente
pedaços de música quase nunca chegou ao
fim quase nunca têm excesso a totalidade
do produto do produto cultural
no entanto nós hoje podemos observar a
pensar com todas essas inovações
tecnológicas nomeadamente uma que é
muito importante a possibilidade de
comunicação audiovisual em tempo real
a música teria proibido esse caráter
essa eficiência comunicativa e essa
capacidade de agregar as pessoas em
torno de 1 do sentimento de pertença
comum
pelo contrário é música ou está cada vez
mais presente no nosso cotidiano
nós temos música telemóvel temos música
na sala de espera
temos músicas com variadíssimas
aplicações da etnomusicologia a
musicoterapia a guerra psicológica como
foi utilizada a tradição já noriega se
refugiou na embaixada do vaticano que as
tropas americanas estiveram
permanentemente como as colunas
gigantescas habitar cm entre consciência
de si para não deixar dormir de tanta
música está onipresente todos os tipos
música todos os que parecem
aparentemente essa essa essa intromissão
do poder político na música deixou de
existir pelo menos a reposição com
excessiva ou menos esse tipo de
discussão política da música deixou de
existir
será que deixou onde é que nós vamos
tentar compreender a importância que o
poder político continua a acontecer na
música
nós temos vários episódios vai mar
centro temos um êxito bandas de heavy
metal foram à bem pouco tempo seguidas e
e aprisionados por blasfêmia temos muito
recentemente um grupo punk na indonésia
que foi preso pela pela pela
as autoridades policiais e religiosas e
foram reencaminhados por um cantor de
educação onde os seus moicanos foram
tapados e as vestes que os associados ao
movimento punk foram destruídos
temos também se também pensar em só
acontece nos países do mundo
só parece que os países mais ou menos
tema teocrático
desenganem-se após o 11 de setembro foi
publicado um foi à boa maneira
inquisitória foi publicada uma lista de
bandas e músicas proibidas prejudicavam
o esforço de guerra ao terror na
população americana inclui bandas como
os all blacks o temas como bips as
chances do do ano
portanto esta ação repressiva do estado
é é a vela é importância que as
autoridades políticas
ainda hoje continuam a atribuir à música
o que aprendeu o poder político
entretanto ao longo de todo este
processo é toda essa reação violenta
despertava uma uma reação proporcional
que o que aprendeu ao longo dessa
relação foi atuar de uma forma muito
mais difusa e cada vez mais a ação da
discussão política das voz dissonante é
feita através da modificação dos
produtos culturais
nomeadamente as populações africanas
escravizadas no novo mundo foi proibido
o uso de tambor numa tentativa de livrar
vá em pir dificultar a criação de vídeos
e desligar a preservação da identidade
cultural
ora essa proibição que era que era que é
integrada pelo pelo proprietário
escravagistas mundo uns anos depois
naval são dos instrumentos da população
branca por parte das populações
realizadas e é um uma das razões uma das
circunstâncias contribuíram e contribuem
para o sentimento rock'n'roll meia dúzia
de anos depois seria uma ameaça muito
maior o poder o poder político então
fazer sinal que deve acabar e já trazia
transversal um pouco a consciência de
estado coisas e nós pensarmos que tudo
isto é logo tudo isso é uma falta que
chega até nós é manipulada
instrumentalizado pelo poder político
facilmente nos impele no sentido da
inércia facilmente nos empenhar no
sentido do cinismo e do conformismo
eu digo exatamente o contrário deve
estimulá los a agir eo que nós fizemos
em conjunto também com o pedro e com a
daniela em viseu em 2003 foi fundar uma
associação cultural foi através do
associativismo e do cooperativismo
fundar uma associação cultural sem fins
lucrativos com uma ação uma vez que não
podemos mudar o mundo porque aumentou de
proporção poder da imensa com uma ação
localizada e focalizada em uma área em
nós consigamos ver mais indiretamente os
resultados e um deus serão mais
impactante à escala local a escala
vicinal as casas aquelas pessoas com
quem nós convivemos todos os dias
o êxito parece um sucesso da iniciativa
foi extraordinário e realmente nós
conseguimos com isso vai criar uma
estrutura alternativa à oferta que
existe
a oferta convencional nesta cidade
despretensiosamente acho que conseguimos
foi realmente houver algum alguma
humanidade
são relações criadas em torno da música
não são já virtuais são humanas são
palpáveis e se não fazer um mundo melhor
pelo menos tornar a experiência vivida
mais gratificante e vou ver um pouco de
serenidade a as pessoas envolvidas
obrigado
[Aplausos]